well all successful people have egos if
you don't learn to check them at the
door
some humility you're not gonna be
successful
[Music]
well thank you so much for being with me
on 20 minute leaders
thanks michael my pleasure appreciate
your project thank you okay so i already
we started this interview i forgot to
hit record
but it's great because it's part of this
whole informality
we know each other from a j ventures a
wonderful fund that they were both at
and
i i what i mentioned before is that i
just get so inspired every time by by
seeing your insights and your
your motivation and your passion for
helping early stage startups
and in in and out of the fun so so just
thank you for
for everything that you're teaching me
through that great program
and and i'm really excited to learn over
these 20 minutes who you are a little
bit better
so let's get right back to where we were
who are you
okay so if i have to define myself and i
think i said it before you forgot the
record
i am a computer architect that's how i
define myself
you started with i just wanna mention i
would venture to say that while at the
beginning of my career i was thinking
i'm an introvert well all engineers need
to be
i'm not exactly an introvert uh
i'm not going to spend a lot of time but
at a certain point of my career when
i'll venture to say i was pushed into it
into engineering management and i was a
chip designer i was doing some
cash control errors
i was told hey take a team lead etc and
one of the things i learned is if you
ask what makes me tick
i'm a product guy which means somebody
has to use the product
and when it took care to me
subconsciously maybe
that i can do it with a team
it takes a village whatever the cliche
better than an individual contributor
i continued as an engineering leader
maybe a unique engineering leader never
left the technology but never forgot
that i have to trust people who are
smarter than me
i'll take only small tasks but i see the
big picture
you mentioned you said you were pushed
into it what does that mean
what does it mean i came to i
came to i okay so
long answer how many in direction i'll
have to remember how
how many pushes and then how many pops
of the stack
but they came to the states
as a young engineer
part of an israeli startup one of the
first
companies in israel that was called the
startup i'm talking early 80s
wow and not going in who the investor i
didn't even know it
was all black and white back then right
it was
i was a chip designer but we actually
used chisels to
design it carving on rocks yeah
i can do jokes as good as you but
to the point of i'm sorry i apologize
you have the erase button so came here
as a young engineer
i mean maybe another indirectional climb
out of it it's not a red hole
technion graduate i started to work as a
large
government military research institute
okay
in israel you can call it rafael so
and the reason i joined i was third year
in the technion they come and say they
jo you joined
uh was kind of the plan hey plans
plans never happen kind of the plan okay
what i'm doing there which had nothing
to do with computers but it was
pattern recognition video analysis etc
we had video at that time but
[Applause]
yeah it will be my thesis
and then maybe phd anyway i joined the
startup
that was doing a super many unique super
mini
in the early 80s never looked back
came to this country kicking and
screaming
really i mean i just got married couple
of
months before we baked the first son
my wife had to take a leave of absence
and 30 years
38 years after it i'm still here but now
going back i never forget the pops and
pushes on on the stack what does it mean
push so i came here
i started to work as a designer for an
american company you acquired the
israeli startup
with colleagues of mine and
my domain was whatever
doing the cache controller and
at a certain point and i had no
pretension i didn't even know i'm saying
it
at a certain point push means
my mentor at that time and i i use the
term mentor a lot because
if i'll ever write a book i'll write it
about all the people i learned from
basically said you should lead the team
and then it was we'll make you a manager
and then
and i was when i say
kicking and screaming again the push was
no
i just wanna write test vectors for what
i design
i hope i explained the push so somebody
saw something
and and here you are he was right he was
right
right okay so now fast forward you've
been an svp at quite a few organizations
huge organizations and so talk to me a
little bit about your
what is it what is the role of a senior
vice president of engineering what does
that even mean
what does it mean
so a huge means after the acquisitions i
mean
i have been part of three startups all
the companies that were startup they
ended in acquisition
usually i didn't stay the current one i
stayed
not gonna ask why but what does it mean
it means responsibility for delivering
delivering the product i'm not the
architect anymore although i try to
remain
as technical it means
you asked you said that at the end
you'll ask me about
it means three things it means people
because
are you only going to do it yourself no
no no no no i'm not defining myself but
it means
people it means a project which has a
timeline nothing works explained
etc and it means a product which means
working with
product management customers etc to
define the
mvp etc it's all about the delivery
right but when i say people i never
forget that
an engineering leader and i had the term
svp vp et cetera it's really an
engineering leadership is about
people and remembering
that you delegate to people who are
i hate the term because we don't do a
competition smarter than you
and you delegate to people who
cover for your weaknesses right okay so
none of us has all the strengths and
weaknesses but that's really the
definition of the job and
between those in those three startups
depending where the investor where
and two of them almost died and i had to
re
help redefine the company by the way
when i say i
it's just a habit but i remember that
it's never
i uh it's us
but
how many people are you leading now
about
300 i've let the thousand before but you
don't lead him directly
and but you're defining the culture
you're defining
what what it means to to develop to
deliver the product
what how do you lead a thousand people a
thousand people it doesn't matter if
it's direct or if it's or you know
there's different steps to the pyramid
at the end they're looking at you as the
as the as the person who's defining the
strategy and trajectory is as simple as
one word maybe two and again
i'm trying i'm not a clarity
you have to explain what's the true
north
because in order to get to a product
if it's an innovative product there are
challenges
you are going to remember that you're
not gonna
so you have to make sure you're getting
into the true north
you have to help them realize
where do you move resources for one task
to another
when i say true north think how
a chimpanzee or gorilla moves in the
jungle if you watch him
you'll see he jumps from limp to limb
from three to three
he knows where he's going my job was to
make sure that
we know where we are going because at
certain
times at the project you don't know
where you're going
clarity is key what really do we need to
expect
run interference because especially in
large company
acquisitions there is a huge
contingency of people who are trying to
help you but they are not stakeholders
let's leave it at this at the startup
it's easy it's small
all the management team came together
it's much easier to do a project with 10
engineers and i was that's how i started
and then grow to 100 and work in a large
company
and last but not least and sorry if i'm
preaching
especially with engineers
be simple don't send videos don't behave
as an exec
i was told i'm not the right exec which
is true
but apparently i do something right but
i am not the typical
i'm not a typical exec i don't
communicate by long emails i don't send
the
long emails you stand in front of them
you try to do some
small coffee gatherings well i can't now
so i do it at zoom i
i need to change my headshot because
the headset is now glued to me but back
to
what i was saying
they remember what you say so say what
you mean mean what you say and deliver
because it's all about trust in my
opinion
amazing and i think that's inspiring to
hear at a time when uh
you know even in small companies and i
have the benefit of also seeing a lot of
my friends
going to all these different startups
and you know here in palo alto it's
there's a lot of excitement over
everything that's happening you know
even
somebody who's in a leadership role in
the tiniest startup i mean
people especially i think my generation
i guess i think a little bit more than
previous generations
enjoy the titles and enjoy the and enjoy
the
the responsibility and and it comes
across
also within the workforce i think at
least from what my friends are telling
me
that why is the my team leader of five
sending me you know these
these crazy pitches and these you know a
sly deck to represent
you know a simple idea why wouldn't they
do a one-on-one with me
which is exactly what you're you're
saying and again i am
atypical i mean it i'm not saying i'm
better or worse or whatever that's my
style
it worked for me i can't tell you if it
works for others
a lot of my colleagues are now
corporate america i use corporate
america i work a lot of japan so
corporate worldwide which is
that means that's it and then there is a
video and a zoom
to 100 people i don't i but i don't and
i admit it
it's my weakness i'm not good at it i'm
much better at one-on-one
the other thing to remember and again
when i learned it and this was my
failure at the beginning
when i learned that things started to
work check
the ego at the door forget that check
the ego at the door
there was a period
i would say in the late
80s mid 90s
that i was thinking i'm the smartest guy
walking the planet because i can design
super computers whatever and
credit to friends credit to my wife
credit to kids credit who told me that
[Music]
okay what i'm about i'm about to make
you a raise
my dusting and that was
quiet an education
and i realized i have an ego well all
successful people have egos
if you don't learn to check them at the
door some humility
you're not going to be successful i mean
others are but
it didn't work for me and it goes
hand in hand with what he told me right
before we started which was
uh you look at the millennials who are
coming in as engineers and you realize
two pretty contradicting things yet
complementary things right
okay so let me start at the high level
so they were born with computers i
wasn't
i never saw a computer until my third
year
at the technion and
okay it shows my age but i told you that
i came here in the early 80s i
was getting my double e
and i had some big simulation
rf simulation in fortran and guess what
the technion had that time at 370 168
and i had to program it on punch cards
and go and submit the job
and learn stuff like job control
language and one of my colleagues only
said
why don't you have an account on tso
and i go what's tso oh it's a time
ceramic option
good how do i get it oh you have to
study computer science so basically i
added computer science and never looked
back
but now to the point so i didn't grow up
with computers but i was lucky
i most of my professional
fun i almost say career when i hate the
term but call it career
was in the 80s and the 90s
and as far as i'm concerned that's the
decade where computer architecture was
defined
and it gave me a
foundation that i still use
because i was doing cache controllers
and i was a designer on a risk
processors
and uh the operating system
was at that time unix system five and
etc etc
i became a much better
software person system person because i
understood operating systems to adapt
that
only a designer of
processors could understand now i say
okay that's the advantage
and that's what i use now to abstract
stuff at a higher level
but when i say that your generation is
much better than me and i envy you
i struggle with the simplicity where you
guys
take microservices and combine it to
kubernetes and whatever and
blah blah blah blah and
i don't say my cat can write in python i
struggle with it i mean
but at a certain point i realized that i
can help
because i can understand stuff they they
don't
because it's so natural so
the foundation of how the processor
works and how the
operating system works and i don't care
is it
virtualized or containerized
or in the cloud still gives me an
advantage i hope i answer why
i have both an advantage and a
disadvantage
i'm a dinosaur but i'm lucky that
dinosaur sorry
but i'm lucky that my professional
learning was at the decade that
processors took a
giant leap no definitely i think
one of the things that i grew up with in
my house which was also you know
my i come from a house where i have
quite quite a strong tech
presence and great mentorship and one of
the things that i was always taught from
from very young is first get the
foundation get the really
understand the foundations learn the
learn the advanced mathematics
understand how things are happening and
then
you'll be able to apply these things as
an abstract layer on whatever
technologies
and what i do see and i agree with you
is that a lot of a lot of engineers
today
they jump straight into python and and
javascript
and today it's it's all commoditized
it's very easy to go
and write a website or write an
application it's much harder to do the
complex and really cool stuff because
that's where the foundation kicks in
and so i completely agree what are you
so excited about now with working with
early stage startups so you've been with
startups yourself as an executive but
now you're also helping invest and
advise
startups so talk to me a little bit
about this this interest of yours that
is uh
over the past decade or so
so working with startups again
mostly at advisory role
and that means on demand
nobody wants your advice unless they
have anything
it goes everywhere from hey can you look
at this problem and use your brain to
tell me i mean most of advice means
what did for me what did i arbitrarily
said
doing the same thing and expecting uh
different results in the definition of
lunacy so yeah
a lot of time it's about sharing i hate
to advise i don't give advice
it's it's basically
wrong but trying to use example and say
here is what i've learned in terms of
the business side
is what the way i help on the technology
only when i asked to do a deep dive we
talked about the foundation
and yeah i agree with you and thanks for
sharing with me i mean
i didn't even know i want to do double e
i started with physics and math and
whatever but
credit to the technion i think still now
even
but definitely at that time the
foundation is much stronger than
hey here is a quarter and we'll teach
you how to write javascript
and nothing against it again i end with
those guys but
uh but it doesn't
be right is the foundation
the cool stuff is the foundation and
that's what i'm trying to
help with and that's not one semester of
uh
learning how to do javascript of course
we're almost out of time and i it why i
don't know why i called it 20 minute
leaders i could have called it 30 minute
leaders
i'd love to ask you my last question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
okay let's speak let's speak from 10 so
direct although i'm american now so i
i talk american in business but that dna
has never
innovative which is trying to and
passionate i was told sometimes relax
okay
the passion will never disappear humble
is my word for ishmael uh it's it's
extraordinary all the things that you've
done and you're still doing yet
you're here talking a with so much
humility about
everything and so and it really
resonates so thank you for the
inspiration and thank you for teaching
me so much
through uh through working together at j
ventures it's really fantastic
and i and thank you that's it thank you
michael
thanks for what you're doing take care